Російські назви вулиць.
Пам’ятники радянським генералам.
Книжки російською та навіть ще з радянських часів.
Російське телебачення в квартирах і
домінуюча присутність церков московського патріархату.
Шість років тому, у квітні 2014 року, прихильники "русского мира"
ледь не перетворили Харків у столицю "Новоросії",
а регіон не вивели зі складу України як самопроголошену
"Харківську народну республіку".
Відтоді на центральній площі міста, навпроти облдержадміністрації,
і стоїть оцей намет.
Цей намет "Все для перемоги" був встановлений 14 вересня 2014-го
на тому самому місці, звідки проросійські, російські сили
атакували нашу ХОДА і повісили російський прапор.
Харків’янин Борис Редін був серед тих проукраїнськи налаштованих
харків’ян, які не захотіли віддавати сепаратистам облдержадміністрацію
після втечі тодішнього губернатора Добкіна.
Редін називає їх "дітьми Путіна", які приїхали в місто з Росії.
Намет, за його словами, активісти встановили,
аби постійно нагадувати владі про наслідки будь-яких дій,
що загрожують суверенітету країни.
Загроза сепаратизму, вважає Борис Редін, досі нікуди не ділася,
адже російський кордон від Харкова - за 40 хвилин їзди,
а в самому місті при владі залишилися ті ж люди, які,
як він вважає, і привели в місто в 2014-му той самий "русский мир".
Саме за цю владу харків’яни голосували
навіть після Майдану у 2015-му.
Ви розумієте, що вони не пов’язують це з тим, що вони зробили.
Вони спочатку "рускомірили" по повній програмі.
Мабуть, отримали гроші, створювали загони "тітушок" у Харкові,
відомі на всю Україну. Але коли дійшло до того,
що тут змінять прапор, місцева влада в особі Кернеса злякалася.
Бо це ж його "корова", він і повинен її "доїти".
А тут прийде хтось з Росії  і почне займатися грабуванням харків’ян!
Тобто він не згодився, і почалися от ці, як-то кажуть, "качєлі" туди-сюди.
З 2010 року до президентських виборів-2019 Харків переважно
голосував за представників партії Віктора Януковича або
за його соратників, які залишилися в політикумі після його втечі.
Відомий харків’янин, письменник і музикант Сергій Жадан не виключає,
що Харків і на місцевих виборах 2020-го не зрадить цій традиції.
Жадан був одним із активних учасників харківського Євромайдану
і пересвідчився, що дійсно проукраїнськи налаштованих людей
у місті значно менше, аніж прихильників чогось російського
чи то радянського, а також орієнтованих
на дружбу з РФ політиків.
Так склалося, на думку Жадана, в першу чергу через те, що
будь-які громадські активності в Харкові багато років придушувалися:
погрозами, побиттям "тітушками", судовими рішеннями тощо.
Незалежну пресу і політиків, опозиційних до влади Януковича,
мера Геннадія Кернеса і ексгубернатора Михайла Добкіна,
тут теж особливо не жаліли.
Над цим довго і наполегливо працював харківський політикум.
Як формувалося харківське політичне поле в 90-х,
нульових роках? Зачищалося фактично інформаційне поле,
зачищалося політичне поле. Як фактично створювався
такий політичний вакуум,
коли є одна сила, вона не скільки ідеологічна, скільки економічна.
Економічно-олігархічно-корумпована.
Тому що назвати Кернеса дійсно політиком - мабуть, це
не зовсім коректно.  Для нього це бізнес.
Якщо влада за складом у Харкові не змінилася після Майдану, то,
мабуть, не надто змінилися і харків’яни, які її обрали
на попередніх виборах у 2015-му, каже Жадан.
За останні п'ять років усі опитування свідчать про високу
підтримку Кернеса городянами. Щонайменше 45-50%
за різними даними. Наразі ризик,
що в Харкові знову вибухне щось сепаратистське, є, але мінімальний,
переконаний Жадан. Мовляв, Харків за ці роки все-таки став
проєвропейським містом.
У Харкові є частина мешканців міста, які радо би підтримали
сьогодні створення ХНР, які би зустрічали квітами російські танки.
Чи таких тут багато, важко сказати.
Просто більшість населення - вони не антиукраїнськи налаштовані
і не просепаратистськи.
Вони в принципі не налаштовані. Вони живуть собі своїм життям,
і їх, за великим рахунком, все влаштовує.  Я думаю, що все-таки
є певний інстинкт самозбереження і у місцевої влади, яка не дозволяє
собі навіть попри тотальне превалювання,
попри таку-от цілковиту  підтримку місцевого населення, різких рухів
і різких заяв, все-таки розуміючи, чим це може завершитися,
чим для того ж таки Кернеса це завершилося у 2014 році.
Успішний Харків, працюючі підприємства,
гідне і мирне майбутнє обіцяють харків'янам з білбордів
понад десяток партій, які висувають своїх кандидатів до міської ради.
На посаду мера претендують 12 кандидатів.
Геннадію Кернесу, який хоче зайняти цю посаду втретє,
опонують такі відомі харків’яни, як підприємець і нардеп від ОПЗЖ
Олександр Фельдман,
чинний губернатор від партії "Слуга народу" Олексій Кучер,
брат ексгубернатора Євгена Кушнарьова, вбитого на полюванні
у 2007-му, - Сергій Кушнарьов.
Від партії "Європейська солідарність" балотується відомий у місті волонтер
Олег Абрамичев.
Майже усі вони передвиборчу боротьбу фактично не ведуть
або ведуть дуже мляво. І це не тільки через необхідність
дотримуватися протиепідеміологічних правил.
За рейтингами і навіть за кількістю білбордів домінує Геннадій Кернес.
Однак, за офіційним даними, він з середини вересня лікується
від коронавірусу в Німеччині. Тож справжньої передвиборчої боротьби
в Харкові - з дебатами, дискусіями тощо, - не велося.
Ми бачимо, що мер фізично не бере учаcть у кампанії.
Ми не маємо точної інформації про стан здоров’я  і про спроможності
виконувати обов’язки міського голови.
Життя непередбачуване. Є різні сценарії.
Один з них - вихід у другий тур деяких нерейтингових кандидатів.
Політологиня Юлія Біденко припускає, що в харківській міськраді
можуть опинитися більше депутатів від проросійськи налаштованої
партії "ОПЗЖ".  Проукраїнські, проєвропейські партії,
громадські активісти, які теж балотуються в раду
від інших сил, можуть знову опинитися  в меншості.
Але, каже політологіня, це вже не буде протистояння
суто проукраїнських і проросійських сил. Це буде боротьба старих партій
з новими, які виникли в Україні в останні 3-4 роки.
Ось у Харкові наочно зараз відбувається боротьба старих еліт
з 90-х із новими елітами 2000-х, тобто
така собі боротьба "бумерів" із "міленіалами",
причому вони конкурують за голоси виборців у кожній ніші.
"Міленіали" проти "бумерів". Харків’яни, які говорять українською,
проти чиновників та мера, які спілкуються російською.
Ті, хто ненавидять Росію, проти тих, хто не проти відносин з нею.
Тема спільної історії України і Росії багато де присутня в Харкові,
як оця скульптура українця і росіянина, які взялися за руки,
на мосту в центрі міста.
Сергій Жадан не очікує від місцевих виборів чогось революційного.
Зміни політичних еліт, на його думку, глобально не відбудеться.
Водночас самеце буде сигналом для громадських активістів.
Ясна річ, що розслаблятися не можна.
Потрібно постійно владі нагадувати, що вона українська,
що вона представляє державу Україну,
що ми всі - громадяни України і є українськими виборцями.
Коли це нагадуєш, то вони це згадують
і на якийсь час заспокоюються.
Намет, який харківські активісти вважають таким собі
"форпостом проукраїнського Харкова", міська влада намагалася
знести вже кілька разів. Активіст Борис Редін упевнений:
намет повинен стояти, доки не буде деокупований Крим
і звільнений Донбас, а загроза сепаратизму в Харкові,
вважає активіст, "лікується" щонайменше проукраїнським мером.
От тільки обрати його Харків, схоже, зможе не на цих виборах.